in mariupol medics are desperate to save
their patients
we ask we beg this doctor says to be
given the chance to save the lives of
injured fighters by evacuating them
two thousand soldiers and as many as one
thousand civilians are holed up here in
the besieged as of stall steel plant
the wives of some of mariupol's
ukrainian defenders had been evacuated
to safety in italy where they now plead
for the evacuation of their husbands we
think that marupal
have to have a chance and not
only civils we come here to
rescue
a live soldiers too
because
sorry
but russia's foreign minister blames the
ukrainians for the humanitarian crisis
there is only one problem
humanitarian corridors which are being
announced on a daily basis
are ignored
by the ukrainian
ultra nationals
but there is no evidence that is true in
fact russian aircraft were bombing the
steel plant again saturday russia also
sent missiles towards odessa in
southwestern ukraine on the black sea
coast ukrainian officials say a missile
hit the airport and has put a runway out
of commission in the northeast in and
around kharkiv ukrainian forces attacked
russians this video provided by the
ukrainian military is said to show
ukrainian forces destroying russian
military assets but russia launched at
least three strikes on the industrial
complex in harkev no desert injuries
were reported